it's great to see you it for the
premiere of whiteford in a blizzard here
at sundance tonight now you're making a
big habit of making movies that are
based on popular books I do well it's it
like making white bird in a blizzard I
was really stoked to make it just
because of Gregg Araki I'm such a fan of
him as director and the opportunity to
work with him doesn't come around very
often because he doesn't make very many
films so that coupled with the poetic
and lyrical script that he provided that
he created based on the book was sort of
a no-brainer I was like I'll do anything
to do this movie now what makes him
special to work with his director he
makes movies that nobody else makes and
he has such a unique tone and such a
unique point of view and voice and and
yeah I mean all of his movies are so
incredibly different and I think that a
lot of directors don't don't necessarily
have the ability to make a wide range of
films and so I also just love how daring
he is and that he's never sold out you
know he does him and he's a real sundogs
best friend as well isn't he definitely
now the movie starts in 1988 isn't it so
you've got that kind of period look to
it how did you enjoy kind of working
that look oh it's so fun oh my god we
got to like we're late eighties grunge
and early 90s yeah it was just so good
so good like dancing a goth club yeah
what are your favorite bits um not
period the music was really is really
great you know a movie soundtrack is so
there we have Cocteau twins and early
night in genell's of course I mentioned
working on lots of films or adaptations
you've got coming up divergent want to
bite insurgent and then leave I mean
what's it like stepping into a world
like that where there's such an
incredible fan base it's huge I mean
it's it's very action films are very
very different you know then then films
like this and it's kind of fun to be
able to dabble a little bit in both
territories I know you didn't know my
birds in a blizzard when you took on
this particular film but we you kind of
aware of the world of Veronica Roth when
you took on divergent um I I didn't
really know it I read the book before I
even read a script so the book is what
introduced me to the diverse
it's been loving something shiny like
symmetry time thank you so much
you